let's talk about how you directed a film
where the subject is very much alive and
is the producer one of the producers on
the film and then you have this terrific
screenplay from Lee Hall and then you
have your own vision so how did you
blend all that together seamlessly III
got the script and a call from Matthew
Vaughn the producer who was working with
Tarun on Kingsman to which Elton was in
and obviously there were discussions
around the piano an on-set amongst these
guys and Taryn and I were very keen to
find some another project after working
together on Eddie the Eagle which we had
a lot of fun with and we really felt we
brought a lot of kind of heart - and so
when Matthews - opened that discussion I
was very quickly trying to engage with
that and obviously I say Taran and I had
a very good working relationship so
those sort of things it's one of those
kind of magical things that you can't
always define that stars a line and you
know things come together and it's in
it's really good and healthy I think to
feel that way about certain projects
that you know you know you're gonna have
this passion for and are gonna require
that Elton as you say as a
larger-than-life personality and the
scripts allowed for that it allowed for
this freedom of imagination and
creativity and I knew that I had a great
ally and collaborator in teheran so that
that was a very exciting and the more I
moved away from a linear kind of biopic
kind of take on things and really
created a story that was sort of more
like all that jazz this was a great
touchstone for us but this lovely idea
of someone unpacking their life and kind
of looking back on it and trying to
figure out how do I make myself better
that was a really interesting and and
exciting approach - so the biopic if
even if you can call this a biopic how
how involved did Elton want to be was he
in meetings did he see a rough cut to
mean was he do you just sort of give you
the story the reins and say I'll see you
at can or how did that work you know why
yeah I mean you know it's not that he
wasn't ever present he was because you
know he is such a larger-than-life
personality and the stories and the
scripts is all derived and and grew out
of conversations with Lee Hall ten
twelve years ago that they were having
and that's and that screenplay developed
from that that then I took on and and I
would sit and talk without and about
about a lot of the big themes and the
relationships in in the script um but
then he did this wonderful thing where
he said you can't just replicate me and
what you you know Tarrant can't just
sing it the way I've sung it you've got
to take it and make it your own you know
it's got to be its its own thing it has
to live in its own way and and he you
know he had a world tour to finish he's
doing this incredible yellow brick road
three years of farewell you know which
is which is absolutely right it's takes
him a long time to say goodbye and it's
which is cry but he did he sort of gave
us that trust and that and that love to
kind of Greg he did we know we took him
drawings and dad dinners and you could
call him but there was a point where I
think he understood that there was no
benefit in him sitting and trying to
micromanage something that needed to fly
needed to find its own voice it needed
to find its own destinies it were and
and he trusted us and let us feel
trusted so Bryce you of course played
Elton's mum Sheila you know unlike some
of the other actors you didn't have the
real-life person to to draw on and even
just chat with or you know mine for
details so how did you find Sheila
without relying solely on the lens of
Elton and his memories yeah I mean I
actually had a lot of personal angst
around that because she she was a real
person
she was actually recently deceased when
when we were shooting and and it was a
really toxic relationship and so when I
first read the script and Dexter and I
talked for quite a while and and and and
I just I was trying to kind of unpack
what was I mean there was clear there
was some sort of narcissism but there
was also other stuff as well and trying
to figure out what led to this
incredibly dysfunctional relationship
that was never explicitly abusive and
yet had such a lasting effect on Elton
and so to and to answer your question
more directly what I did was I talked a
lot to Taryn because he had spent so
much time with Elton and had read so
much of what Elton had written which was
obviously you know it's like when you
have a chat with someone one-on-one for
the first time like meeting them you're
not going to just pour your soul out to
them whereas on the written page of
course you know it's it's more more
insightful and more intimate but I
wasn't totally satisfied with that so I
I like can't even look at you while
saying this I like sought people outside
of production who weren't affiliated
with production who knew her because it
was it was it was just important because
she's a person and yes it was bad it was
very bad between them it was really not
good Jamie
what did Bernie teach you about being
Bernie that's a good question boy he is
a very I just did a CBS Morning Show
with him in the day and they did all
this stuff with like they put like a
whole screen of like 30 albums that
they'd done together and like you know
all these like accolades that that they
had achieved together and he's I would
be so proud of that you know like I
would be like yes like we all did that
we went out and did that to get we
created it together he's like yeah yeah
I did that yeah pretty cool and pretty
cool but I went up to meet him in Santa
Barbara where he lives with his wife
Heather and
and he was very much like that he's very
unassuming and I think he'll be writing
lyrics forever you know he's a sculptor
now which is ironic if I was a sculptor
but then again no he's literally
sculpting sculpting in a studio probably
right now he had no idea that would be
the case you know but to expand on the
Bernie character slightly he was at the
point where we met in the film he had no
idea what his life was gonna be no idea
where it was going
he had an affection for the Arts and
affection for literature great
literature poetry and Tolkien and
literally lying in tall grasses looking
at the clouds this man is a hopeless
romantic you know and he was at the
point where he answers his ad in this
magazine NME magazine where he
faithfully met Elton
he was scraping dead chickens off the
floor and throwing them in an
incinerator so he knew that the only way
he had to write his way out he had to
write his way out of his circumstances
and find someone who once stood him and
could cathartic Lee process his
sometimes quite frankly ramblings almost
say some of his lyrics don't make much
sense I've asked him I said to Elton at
one of these parties that were asked at
Elton do you know what take me to the
pilot means he was like now and Bernie
doesn't know either so you know so that
he is an affection for words
he's affection for putting them in a
certain order and making you and all of
us certainly feel a certain way and
Elton was so eloquent musically fitting
that tone they are they are different
size to each others coin they can't
function without each other yeah so
let's talk about you Taryn I think
everybody should know by now that you
sing every note and every word in this
film
[Applause]
I don't want to say it like this told
you you could sing
I mean who told you to sing like who was
the person who said yep
you're gonna play Elton and by the way
we'd really like you to sing everything
we're not gonna lip-sync or whatever I
really love singing
i-i've always loved it and I think for
many years I think I just sort of
annoyed my friends and family with it
really but I um I've always I've always
felt that it's something I wanted to
make a feature of my professional life
if the opportunity arose and you know
you know when Matthew first asked me
about this three years ago Matthew
Vaughn ah but producer and a great
friend of mine
it just was just this irresistible
opportunity and as they said we'd made
this movie Eddie the Eagle which we were
really really proud of and and we had an
incredible time making it and debts just
creates this atmosphere on set he's I
mean I feel like saying it's because
he's an actor is is reductive it's not
it's not that he's just is just a
brilliant actors director and and I
really felt like I felt really
creatively fulfilled by that project and
so this iteration of this all just felt
really exciting and cool and and and I
love Elton's music as well when I was 17
I auditioned for are we to rather in
London and I your song was my audition
piece when I was 17 and then and then
again at 18 CH they didn't let me in the
first time
so yeah this project was just sorry
there was a point your question I'm just
rambling on anyway ramble like you know
it's always interesting to know like you
know kind of what when did this these
swords cross like when did you think
yeah I'm up to this task and and while
I'm at asking another question how did
you ramped up I mean you I think that's
an important element of the equation is
that you know I didn't want the first
time we went into Abbey Road I didn't
arrive I was up I was a far better
singer by the end of the
and I was at the start I've done singing
before I let my voice to this movie sing
that camera a couple years ago I play
gorilla in it so I actually sang I'm
still standing in that weirdly but I II
so I've always done it and I've always
loved it but through the support of
Dexter and Giles Martin who is the
absolute secret weapon of this film is
the is the Uzi in our belt strap isn't
he here you know the way he's done
musically with this films I think I
personally think extraordinary and he
really helped me grow and find my voice
I'm particularly for the rockiest stuff
because ballad singing is one thing but
that kind of slightly grew up more
gravelly benny in the Jets pinball
wizard Saturday Night's Alright for
fighting sound it needs a bit of grit to
it and that took longer to achieve but
this you know the time I've spent over
the past year making this movie has been
without a shadow of a doubt the most
creatively satisfying stimulating
endeavour of my life so far
and I know I will treasure it forever
it's been an extraordinary journey it's
just been a great joy and and just the
most fulfilling thing and I've made so
many great friends and I'm so proud of
the work we've done and I'm really proud
of the movie really proud of it
[Applause]